[Applause]
so we're very happy to welcome you to
Columbia University to celebrate our
newest Nobel prize-winner newest Nobel
laureate professor yo him Frank
professor of biochemistry and molecular
physics and biological sciences our
congratulations first and foremost to
Professor Frank who shares this prize
with Richard Henderson of the MRC
laboratory of molecular biology in
Cambridge England and Jacques de vache
of the University of Lausanne in
Switzerland I'd also like to acknowledge
your hemes wife Carol Saginaw in the
front Lee Goldman executive vice
president and Dean of the faculties of
Health Sciences and medicine at Columbia
University Medical Center whom I'll turn
this over to in a moment
John cotesworth the Provost of the
University Richard Axel University
professor at Columbia and also a Nobel
laureate and Martin Marty Chaffee 2008
laureate Tom maniatis who leads the
precision medicine initiative and also
was the chair of biochemistry Liang Tong
chair of the department of biological
sciences and all of you from the
Columbia University Medical Center and
the Department of Biological Sciences in
Morningside who are here to celebrate
this moment from his lab in the black
building at the Columbia University
Medical Center professor Frank was
previously the winner of the 2017 Wiley
Prize and the 2014 Franklin medal for
the methods he devised to turn images
taken by electron microscopes of
thousands of individual molecules at
different angles into a finely detailed
three-dimensional representation allows
all of proteins protein molecules of
life to be seen
this is the extraordinary work that has
been recognized by the Nobel Committee
professor Frank joins more than 80 past
and present Columbia faculty members and
alumni over the years who have been
awarded Nobel prizes in a wide variety
of disciplines from neuroscience to
economics this year's prize is a
testament to the excellence of our
biomedical research which brings
together faculty members from across
both these Medical Center uptown and
Morningside Heights but today is
professor Frank's day and we are proud
to have him as our newest Columbia Nobel
laureate and let me just say personally
this is the kind of work that usually
dates back many many years and even
decades and so it's in truth something
that we share with many institutions in
the world of basic research and this is
something that we take as an affirmation
of what it is we do in academic work in
fundamental research a person who lives
by a desire to understand something
better in the world is driven to do that
and sort of selflessly pursues that to
the point where new knowledge has
developed that has a profound effect on
humanity so we take pride because this
is a symbol of what we do not always as
well as these individuals by any means
but we strive for that so professor
Frank congratulations to you on this
very special day now
[Applause]
and now word from legally well I'd like
to reaffirm what president Bollinger
said also congratulate Carol but as you
said this is the outcomes day it's
really extraordinary and very special he
will probably tell you that at 5:18 when
he was more or less awakened he wasn't
necessarily sure whether it was the
Nobel Prize Committee calling or the dog
simply blocking to be walked but
fortunately it was the former as well as
the latter dr. Frank has really been a
pioneer in the development of car
electron microscopy as you heard a
technique that provides imaging at a
level that previously was not possible
well surely remark all about him is this
combination of being a developer of a
new method that allows for pictures and
measurements that previously were
impossible but also the extraordinarily
innovative application of that method
initially to the ribosome which is that
cells Factory and groundbreaking work
describing how the ribosome works at a
level that previously was not possible
papers in nature for example showing how
the ribosome works in the parasite that
causes African sleeping sickness and
leading to ideas about how that disease
could be potentially treated most
recently has worked with other
colleagues that the Medical Center is
focused on ion channels the little holes
in the membrane through which ions
traverse and send the signals and make
the cells communicate and work together
again groundbreaking work dr. Franck was
born in Germany during World War II to
receive his undergraduate degree in the
University of Freiburg spent a fair
amount of time in Munich did some work
at Berkeley and came to the US about 30
years ago
to join the wodsworth lab and all bein
as we said people have often contributed
at multiple institutions we were very
fortunate to recruit yakima here in 2008
a primary appointment of biochemistry
the secondary appointment of biological
sciences and is from his lab in the
black building and in collaboration with
the New York structural biology Center
he's continued to his groundbreaking
work
I've been supported by the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute by the national suits
of health and also by a philanthropist
including lynn shostack whose gift of
the cryo and electron microscope has
really helped us move this program
forward dr. Frank has been a member of
all the right societies but in reality
today's award takes precedence over all
of that I want to thank dr. Frank's
colleagues and biochemistry who helped
us recruit him here who have helped him
with his research but again become what
you've done is truly extraordinary
Columbia Club University Medical Center
are proud of you we look forward not
only to honoring your past work but also
knowing there's great work ahead
important questions to be answered and
this is not quite the beginning but we
know there'll be a number of
extraordinary accomplishments and
discoveries in your future so may have
everyone at Columbia club University
Medical Center congratulations
[Applause]
well this can this is an extraordinary
day for me very touching
humbling experience because I know that
so many new things are discovered all
the time and it's sort of an the shots
are very did the odds are very long to
to get me to this place and I just
really I'm supposed to be brief in my
heart marks on only one to say that I
wouldn't be here without the incredible
support by very gifted students that had
the privilege to have with me and be
able to train the postdocs and students
research associates who all contributed
pieces of this you know immense puzzle
and so I I really like to express my
appreciation to to Carol my wife for the
long and patient indulgence for for my
absences you know mental absences which
now you know how they have been spent
and I'd like to also since as tink
Altman was mentioning much of the time
here in America was spent at
what'swhat's center
what's Lucinda was a very nurturing
environment and for quite some time I
was able to develop these his methods
but I'd like to say that the move to
Columbia was he was very instrumental in
me able to reach out and develop
contacts and friendships with colleagues
over departments across departments and
I was also able to draw from brilliant
students that I was able to recruit here
and altogether they moved to Columbia
was wasn't was a milestone for me and
I'm very grateful to my colleagues
faculty colleagues to the Dean and
president for making all this possible
and we are we add in an important
transition because many people want to
capitalize on this on this new
technology and so the support for an
instrumentation Center and crime
facility is it's extremely important to
make the dreams of many of the people
here come true and there has been a
wonderful support and there were
generous gifts
in that that have made possibility
acquisition of new instrumentation so
thanks very much well very confusing
experiment experience you know because
we mentioned this this dog and we've
been anxious every morning because it's
been waking up earlier and earlier and
and today I I was I was sure it's gotta
be walking up by the dog but instead the
this phone call arrived and then when
the phone when the phone rang I I wanted
to actually be sure that Carol didn't
dismiss it as a crank call because I
knew the sensitivity of the date and so
we're sure enough there wasn't a Swedish
accent and then everything that followed
so it was amazing and all I could say
over and over again this this is
wonderful news I didn't know and
anything else to say to these people in
in Sweden and they kept apologizing for
waking me up so early
[Laughter]
[Applause]